un autre genre de sport moins dangereux
le tennis il n'y aura pas de finale 100%
serbe a chez les dames à roland garros
la numéro un mondiale la belge justine
henin s'est logiquement qualifié le
spectacle est très visuel il est aussi
de plus en plus au nord
julien benetteau zidène berkous la voix
l'a réduite au silence maria sharapova
en demi finale de roland garros ces cris
stridents n'ont guère impressionné ana
ivanovic 6-2 6-1 les mauvaises langues
diront que la jeune serbe a fait taire
la russe
car voici ce que nos oreilles n'auront
plus désormais à subir
non j'ai essayé de ne pas trop y penser
parce que j'ai mes coups à jouer
j'ai essayé de faire abstraction savoir
de ne pas trop faire attention à elle
en matière de vocalises sharapova est la
digne héritière d'une certaine monica
seles qui faillit bien rendre folle la
française nathalie tauziat à wimbledon
cette année un rugissement de sharapova
a même été mesuré à 101 décibels plus
bruyants qu'une tondeuse à gazon mais
indispensable à son jeu si on lui
interdit je dirais donc de crier ça va
complètement modifier qu'à son approche
du tennis pas son jeu mais c'est clair
ça va elle l'a déstabilisé donc
finalement ça va se retourner contre
elle l'écrit n'étant pas interdite par
le règlement
sharapova mais aussi williams et nadal
sont devenus des adeptes du tennis à
gorge déployée où les champions de
l'intox c'est selon cet après-midi la
belge justine henin s'est elle aussi
qualifiée pour la finale en battant
facilement la serbe jankovic
sans un écart de voix numéro un mondial
du jeu en silence